anger and frustration with Argentina's
political class runs high in this poor
neighborhood in Buenos Aires
Horacio Perez a retired sailor says his
200 a month pension is not enough to
live on
we cannot buy we cannot eat a kilo of
potatoes a sweet potato a tomato is
unaffordable how do we live we cannot
live like this and worse if you're
retired I know people who line up in
Banks to beg for a loan it's sad
inflation has been over 120 percent in
the past year and many residents here
are quick to express their deep
disappointment with what they say is the
constant failure of Argentina's economy
people in places like this one are the
hardest hit by inflation and by
Financial instability and many voted for
the far-right candidate Javier melaye
never minding that many of the radical
proposals that he has for Argentina's
economy could have a huge impact on
Argentina's Forest
calls himself a Libertarian he not only
wants to dollarize the economy but also
shut down the central bank which he
blames for the skyrocketing inflation in
the country
he also questions Argentina's free
public health care and education systems
once the undecided waters are removed we
can say that we're in a balance of
thirds the undecided voters in general
tend to be quite angry therefore we have
the chance to get into runoff if we go
into runoff remember this speech because
we are speaking in front of an expert of
argentin nation
Argentine bonds fell around 12 percent
on Monday the US dollar in the parallel
Market seemed Unstoppable and the
government evaluated its currency around
20 percent to cope with a Market's
pressure
supporters of malaysay they voted for
him because they're tired of what they
call our useless politicians
I went and bought a hundred dollars
yesterday so I could save nobody can
save here so I sold them again I hope
there is change come on melee
the next few months will be filled with
political uncertainty but people in
Argentina fear it will translate into
higher prices that nobody for now seems
to be able to control
Buenos Aires
foreign